chair drops out of her new TV movie the  Oscar winner was supposed to start  shooting the Lifetime movie Flint but  today issued this statement quote I will  be unable to leave Los Angeles during  the scheduled filming as I am dealing  with a serious family issue that  prevents me from going on location for  the April filming a source tells us cher  is concerned about her 90 year old  mother's health  she is not ill but somewhat fragile the  film about the Michigan city's water  contamination crisis was a passion  project for Cher  to help the residents of the city she  personally donated almost two hundred  thousand bottles of water she also says  she was looking forward to telling the  story the producers plan to move ahead  with the movie and we will certainly  continue to follow the story to bring  you all the latest developments all you  have to do is go to our website ET  online.com  [Music]